dominic kane reporting there some
breaking news coming to us out of egypt
the senior leader of the muslim
brotherhood has died in cairo's
notorious scorpion prison at the age of
66.
assam al-aryan was a doctor and an mp he
worked to promote democratic principles
within the muslim brotherhood malaria
was also a founding member of the
egyptian organization for human rights
he was arrested in 2013. our
correspondent jamal
al-shal joins us now jamal what else do
we know about the circumstances
surrounding his death
well the conditions inside egypt's
prisons
prior to the uh global pandemic of uh
kovaid were already uh extremely uh
poor according to human rights
organizations there have been numerous
reports both by
amnesty international and human rights
watch talking about overcrowding talking
about torture talking about the
lack of medical uh assistance being
provided to those who were
uh chronically suffering from illnesses
uh as dr assam larian was and others
inside egypt's prison post kovit there
have been
a lot more uh concerns because of
obviously the overcrowding because of
the
lack of sanitary sanity their sanitary
rather
standards as well as because of the lack
of medical treatment there we've heard
of several
people dying over the past few weeks in
egyptian
prisons dr being the most prominent
there was also a prominent
egyptian journalist who was arrested put
into jail for a couple of weeks and the
day
he was released uh was also tested
positive and shortly died after it
what's significant
about dr larian is that he is somebody
who was one of the icons of the muslim
brotherhood not just
within egypt but also internationally he
was a spokesperson for
the group uh he was one of the few who
could speak english amongst his
leadership and therefore
made a lot of media appearances there he
was seen to be more
of the quote-unquote liberal wing of the
muslim
uh brotherhood he was somebody who was
also very vocal against the
mubarak regime as well and actually when
the january 25th
protest took place he was one of the few
who encouraged
the muslim brotherhood's followers from
the first second to actually participate
in those uh protests against uh
the uh uh against the rule of hosni
mubarak obviously when the coup
took place and he was a member of
parliament prior to that he went into
hiding for a couple of weeks only to be
uh uh hounded by the security forces of
ab fatahs or at least
of the military at the time who was in
control then therefore was then
arrested and has been in jail since
there were calls from his family
for the past few months for urgent
medical attention uh to be given to
him however they were not reciprocated
by the authorities and ultimately
he met his fate as did other muslim
brotherhood leaders uh whilst they were
in jail if they're in jail or if they've
been in jail
i mean i want to ask you what this does
what this means
for and to the muslim brotherhood but
it's not the same organization it was
in 2012 in egypt it's not the same
organization it's been since
its foundation actually in reality i
mean as much as they would like to
claim that they are still have the uh
power and influence that they use
through the realities
that has waned uh hugely primarily
because
its top three echelons of leadership uh
have either been killed
arrested or have fled the country but
what this does uh maybe is more of a
psychological
uh impact to both the muslim brotherhood
but also to wider
egyptian society because particularly
somebody like assam larian who
as you mentioned there wasn't just a
member it wasn't just a member of muslim
brotherhood he was a member of
parliament but also he was
one of the leaders of the egyptian
doctors union or egyptian medical
syndicates
as they call it which is one of the
biggest unions in uh
egypt he had an outreach beyond the
muslim brotherhood so when somebody like
that dies
in prison and he's only 66 years old it
will
highlight yet again the uh undemocratic
nature or the
uh flaunting of human rights by the
egyptian authorities now
whether that will anger people or
whether it will make them succumb more
to a reality of
well they live under what many would
describe as a dictatorship
and therefore there's no point trying
that's the impact that's going to
uh have but what we've seen now with
several different
leaders within the muslim brotherhood
then obviously most notably the former
president
muhammad morsi dying in jail as you say
they essentially decimated that
leadership of the muslim brotherhood so
if it were to ever return
at least on the ground it would only
ever do so with
new faces uh and and new personalities
okay jamal many thanks jamal al-shal our
correspondent there tracking that story
for us